it's a fun ass weekend bucket list thing
for sure so we went to this after party
that red bull hosted that dude from
riverdale showed up uh he's the asian
guy he like has like some controversy
with like kurt cobain's
wife about like stealing a guitar yes
this dude ah ross butler yeah
of course so ross butler denies
involvement in bizarre plot to murder
francis bean
cobain's ex-husband over kurt's guitar
yeah
i'm just not even going to try and
unpack that yeah he's just yeah yeah
he's just weirdest part is that middle
name is bean you know i'm kind of
laughing because
it's austin and
you know
everyone's saying like keep austin weird
and the city doesn't feel that weird and
then like for that dude to walk in i was
like that's kind of weird yeah it's like
medium celebrity and then
this driver
he's like
he's like the son of like a russian
oligarch everybody hates him his name's
nikita mazzapin he walks into the club
and he's walking in like no security no
one's even like looking at this dude i
was just thinking like that must be so
weird to like get out of a formula one
car and to be doing like the most
exclusive thing ever to go to some like
rando club in austin
and no one knows who the [ __ ] you are at
all
it's just like
walking around just uninhibited like a
few nerds were letting like me were like
that's the guy i felt like
string theory existed there because
the like a hot ass carrot top was in the
club okay
like he looked i took a picture i i was
too afraid to like get his face there's
no really other way to describe it i
took a picture on the back look at this
[ __ ] we can we can post this he's got
like
i'll send it to the thread he's got like
the same hair he literally looks like
carrot top but like four inches taller
like chiseled face like slim and like
wearing like eyeliner yeah like it looks
like his mustache was uh
it was like really maintained
and so you know maybe just being a
[ __ ] i keep elbowing people like yo
carrot tops here because you know the
dude from riverdale's here nikita
mazzapin's here why wouldn't [ __ ]
characters so that just that you saw
some weird babies yeah keep watching
weird that just kind of became a meme i
just tell people like yo i didn't know
this person was here i'm like kind of
laughing at like all these you know
characters in the club and then i go to
take a piss and i think one of the this
is one of the funniest things i've seen
in my entire life it looks like what is
a
civil war reenactment captain
he's got uh
like a coat on with jeans and i don't
like some like
racing oriented hat he is standing at a
stall and he's pulling the door open as
i'm coming into the bathroom he's like i
need to use this
and there's like a shadow in there like
there's clearly someone in there he's
like well i i need this
and i'm like first of all why are you 60
in the club that's nuts
and then he just arbitrarily goes well
all right then and he wa and he walks
out of the bathroom and
he leaves
so then the guy who is in there walks
out and he's talking to his friend who's
at the urinal the guy's like what the
[ __ ] was that he's like he opens the
door and he says i need to use this and
i say milk me man
what what kind of a comeback is that i
don't know i mean it worked yeah it got
him out of the bathroom i was like
i was like yeah that's weird
that is weird it's like they don't know
how to cuss or something
i need to use this milk me man milk me
[ __ ]
get over here grip on my teeth you want
to use this toilet oh no
i don't want to do that make me spray
like the little cow that i am
make me squirt come on come on milk me
my mother milk me so then it gets better
so that happens i'm chuckling i'm like
god damn it this place is strange
then
um
we're at this table and uh i'm with uh
i'm gonna always [ __ ] up his last name
uh kale sarge you know cowboy kale from
tick tock you know so him and his boy
aaron
and this coked out frat dude pulls up to
him he's like you know he's a big dude
he's like his jaw is twitching his eyes
are big he's like you're the dude from
tick tock right
i love your [ __ ] i put all my boys on
tick tock and we watch you dance man you
can [ __ ] dance man
your [ __ ] is sick he's just going in and
kale's like yup yup just like
entertaining it like being nice and then
it's going on really long kayle's like
[ __ ] dude i like he kind of like shoots
me look like i gotta tap dude it's
it's getting uncomfortable
so he's like oh i want you to be my
friend aaron kind of like as an escape
pod so then
kale kind of like floats away and this
dude is going in on aaron now he's like
that's all i can see i can't really hear
the conversation this is like secondhand
from aaron but i guess at some point in
the conversation he goes
you've been to austin before the gay
bars here are sick
and aaron's like oh yeah
then he says the guy goes i have to
stand to do this there's literally no
other way to do this
okay he goes
so crazy
he's looking at aaron and he's like
yeah the gay bars are sick
are you
just walks away
[Laughter]
asking him if he's gay
and then it's like he like his brain
like was like no you're gonna expose
that you're gay so he's like aaron just
like i see the guy walk away and aaron
turns to me and he's like
i think that guy just tried to [ __ ] me
and i was just like dying laughing at
him like collecting the phrase and
putting it back in his face like are you
no no
aaron's like that guy didn't say bye he
didn't say later like nothing just are
you i like that he tried to ask first
right yeah by using the gay bar thing
yeah it was smart but it didn't really
work no gay bars you're sick
is that something you might be
interested in going to
i was crying because
when aaron retold to me he told him for
sure the gay bars here are sick for sure
for sure
first resin
like for sure
you for sure want to go
you for sure want to check one out milk
me man milk me
[Laughter]
okay like in a good way or like how do
you want to be milked
[Laughter]
are you saying that as like an insult or
like
a like an offer i just want you to milk
me man that had me like you know howling
because it's just so funny to like
be all like hopped up on coke and you're
like this big ass dude and then you get
insecure and then just like dip out and
then
the last thing that had me dying was
one of the guys was like he's clearly
like a promoter there
and
someone else is like he listens to the
podcast he's like dude i love the tmg
podcast i'm like thank you bro then this
boy walks up who's the promoter and he's
like what's up brother what's your name
i'm like no well he shakes my hand he's
like yeah you know i knew you look
familiar i i know you're from some [ __ ]
i'm like yeah what do you do
i'm like what you just said i look
familiar and i'm like ah you know
i got this podcast with my friend maybe
only from that and he's like yeah yeah
hey listen
if you need anything and at this point
he like grabs my hand like this and he's
just holding it and he's like
i could you know
i can make it comfortable for you
anything you need what
i mean legal stuff not not just illegal
stuff
yeah you know no what was he offering
you it's he's like doing this for a
minute and he's like we gotta we you
know he's like come up behind the dj
booth party with us you know you know
anything you need i can make it happen
anything you need anything you need
anything you need i'm like
you want to sell me coke like
like just say it you know
it's like this weird like
not very like discreet under the table
[ __ ] he shakes my hand i'm not
exaggerating like five or six times just
keeps anything you need brother you
should have asked him for something
weird like
what about you have fireworks yeah
it's like what well you said anything
i don't know what are the rules here
legal not legal i mean i just want a
firework i just wanted like a roman
candle or something or like or like some
yummy like buffer for like some not a
buffer for fish
i meant like the weird like banned fish
that you can die from you know blow fish
yeah is that what it is yeah you got you
got blowfish
anything you need brother though do you
have vegetable broth
yeah yeah yeah i'm going home to make a
killer soup and i just
i forgot to get it on my way out i would
love a vegetable broth and a bag of
grapes if you don't do you have
the milk of a fully grown male man
you